chairman good evening everybody and
welcome to this meeting of performance
governance and audit committee on
Thursday the 16th of November
2023 my name is councelor Vanessa Bell
and I'm the chairperson of this
committee there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hands up to
indicate if you wish to speak and I will
invite you to speak at the appropriate
time could I ask members to avoid
approaching the top table as this could
create interference with the cameras and
live stream and please note that the
YouTube live stream sound recording is
dependent on the correct use of the
microphones therefore can I ask that
when invited to speak you remember to
turn on your microphone and turn it off
when finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible finally I would like to welcome
attending remotely Mr htson and Mr aduni
from Deo council's external Auditors and
in the chamber we have our new
colleagues from
boo thrown me there by waving at me our
new colleagues from Boo the council's
internal Auditors Mr eron winter and Mr
Andrew Billingham on my left
also in attendance in the chamber for
the internal audit item of business is
Mr Paul Brooks from chelsford city
council so thank you very much
everyone item two apologies for absence
we have none as far as I'm
aware which moves us on to item three
minutes of the last
meeting it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 28th
of September 2023 found on pages 5 to 12
are approved as a true and accurate
record I so moov do I have a
second thank you councel Thompson can we
uh any matters of
accuracy before we agree those no can we
agree those by
sense super thank you item four matters
AR Rising so it's recommended that the
matters AR rising from the minutes held
on of the meeting on the 28th of
September on pages 13 to 14 are noted I
so move do I have a seconder thank you
Thomson lovely item five disclosure of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-reg interests relating to items
of business on the agenda having regard
to paragraph 9 and appendix B of the
code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
also required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting item six we have no public
participation so let's move straight on
to item seven which you can find on
pages 15 to
56 the report of the external auditor of
the on the audit for the year ended
2021 so we have Mr Lucas Mr
htson Mr adeny and Miss J remotely as
well I believe on this
item who's going first if I just
introduce the report and then I'll pass
to uh Paul huon who's the associate
partner at um deits super thank you
thank you um thanks chair so the purpose
of this report is to provide the
council's external auditor deits with
the opportunity to report the key
findings of their audit to those charged
with governance um prior to them issuing
their opinion on the 2020 21 statement
of account
um and their report is appended to this
um at appendix
one so um Delights have completed their
substantive work on the audit of um that
Year's
accounts um and it's within the terms of
reference of this committee that um
there is a requirement to review their
opinion on those
accounts um I think that's probably all
I say in context and I'll pass over to
Paul to then present the findings of his
report thank you thank you
thank you very much
um yeah just some guidance if possible
please what's the committee's preference
do you want me to take this page by Page
or do I assume that it's readed and just
pick out the highlights members are we
happy with highlightslight highlights
Please Mr hon would be fine thank you
okay then excellent so if I take you to
page 19 of your pack um you have the the
outlining status of our audit um as at
the date of the issuing this report our
audit was almost complete we've got a
few housekeeping matters to attend to
which we intend to address tomorrow and
in the early part of next week and based
on the work we concluded then I
anticipate being able to issue an
unqualified unmodified audit opinion on
the Affairs of the council for the year
ended 31st March 2021 I realized that is
going a long way back in time uh but we
have finally got here um as I say on
page 19 there so I'm going to keep
trying to quote my own page num so give
me a second with that um the reasons for
the delays are set out on that page um
there was a significant rework required
in terms of the agent versus principal
error we had a few Corrections needed to
the properly plant and equipment
valuations we have difficulty obtaining
evidence in respect of the grow internal
areas in order Ral
assets um the res statement of the
accounts needed to correct for the
failure to depreciate major assets there
was a restatement needed the prior
primary statements because they didn't
balance the cash flow needed restating
for the same reason and members may be
aware of the significant hoo-ha there
was about infrastructure assets at the
back end of last year that affected the
whole sector uh which caught you up as
well um we do say there will give you an
all these matters are now I'm pleased to
say concluded and I am satisfied that
thanks to the efforts of the finance
team and all my colleagues that we now
believe the financial statements are
fairly stated and present a true and
fair position of the council's State of
Affairs um taking you on over the page
to page 20 um the other element of work
that we have to do is our value for
money work
in order to sign the council's opinion
on the financial statements I need to
have satisfied myself there are no
significant weaknesses in the
arrangement of ski value for money I'm
happy to say that the work we've
concluded does give me that um
confidence that there are no significant
weaknesses you will in due course get an
Auditor's annual report which will set
out the detail of my findings in respect
of value for money but and there will be
some recommendations in there however
none of them are sufficiently severe
that I believe that I need to raise a
significant weakness in your audit
opinion which is as good as it gets you
know we don't do superlatives we just do
no significant
weakness um just closing off that page
20 um there are a number of um special
powers which sounds very grand for what
it is that the auditor has to issue
reports in the public interest or to uh
issue statutary notices and and the like
uh we did not receive any formal queries
objections from electors and respect to
these financial statements and there
were no matters brought to my attention
which required me to exercise my powers
under the local audit and accountability
act so taking you on
to uh page 23 the PAC uh what you have
here are the significant risks and that
runs through page
23 and
24 and we had two significant risks of
the management override controls which
we are required to assume is a risk in
all financial statement audits as a
result of things like Enron and Worldcom
and parat and partis Valery uh all these
names you might recognize from major
corporate collapses and over failures um
so we are require to assume that there
is a risk of fraud in the M overline of
controls and um we set out on this page
the work that we do respect of that so
we look at your controls we we test a
sample of journals we look at your
accounting estimates and I'm happy to
say that we didn't identify any issues
with management over controls and we
didn't have any significant matters to
raise with the committee in respect of
that
brilliant uh in respect of the covid-19
related income over the page of 24 this
was our significant risk in respect of
Revenue recognition um the key things
here were making sure that You'
recognize the revenue you were entitled
to and you apply the agent versus
principle concept correctly now this was
one of the things that resulted in a
very significant correction to the
financial statements we did look at the
desire implementation of your controls
and as we set out in our control
recommendations on
pages uh your pages 31 onwards um we
concluded there weren't any effective
controls in respect of the evaluation of
covid Grants between agent and principal
now that might sound harsh it was a bit
of a one-off and if you it's very
difficult but you cast your mind back to
where we were at that time um it was a
very different world so whilst it is a
significant risk whilst it is a
significant finding um I wouldn't
necessarily read anything particularly
broader into the fact that that control
wasn't designed and therefore wasn't
implemented um we did require
significant correction to the financial
statements the CIS did change
significantly L uh we also have to have
a new node added to the account to set
out the agent versus principal
Arrangement but again I'm happy to say
that here we are now many many months
old we have got there and we are now
satisfied the financial statements are
correct uh in terms of the Define
benefit pension scheme on page 25 I
don't propose to say it all for long
about that it's a big number you get the
ACT to advise you on it
um we did have a very small issue on it
around uh Goodwin but other than that we
didn't have a lot to say but because
it's such a big number because it is a
judgment we are required to sh around it
in terms of the valuation valuation of
property assets on page 26 again not a
significant risk but an area of focus
just because of the scale of it um we
did encounter a number of issues here uh
so we found some errors in the actual
valuations themselves which were
corrected we found some errors in the
application of depreciation respect to
valued properties we did experience some
difficulties in obtaining evidence
around the inputs to the
valuation but again whilst we've made a
number of recommendations and whilst a
number of Corrections have been made to
the financial statements we are now
satisfied that your financial statements
in the spectum but property asset
valuations are now fairly stated um
there are a lot of recommendations in
this space in our report um obviously
you're not going to address them for the
21 accounts the 22 accounts all the 23
accounts cuz you've already written all
of those um so it's given for your
information to address going forward uh
for the 23 24 financial
statements um we do identify the errors
that we found at the bottom of page 26
on the right hand side
um none of them were so big none of the
remaining ones were so big that c a
great concern the one the only one that
was significant we got you to address
for in respect of infrastructure assets
which was a big issue for the sector um
we worked with the team we identified
some things had as infrastructure asset
were really infrastructure assets we
identified some things that are in
infrastructure assets that didn't really
exist uh because they were double
counted um you have ad adopted the new
uh approach to infrastructure assets um
which is in line with guidance um so
quite a lot of Corrections a bit of
documentation that needs to be tightened
up just housekeeping stuff but again I'm
going to keep saying it we got there
eventually it's been painful but we're
now satisfied that this balance is
fairely
stated and I'm going to take you past
page 28 because it talks about value for
money I've already told you all you need
to know I don't have any significant
weaknesses my report will follow into
course uh I will then take you past page
29 uh page 30 is just some fairly
standard boiler plating about what we do
and don't do on your narrative for and
your annual governance statement Pages
31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39 40 41 are all
recommendations which are given for your
attention uh and for your action some of
them are repeats of earlier
recommendations some of them are new I
don't propose to read them out to you uh
I'm sure if members have got any they
want to D dig into we can do that in the
questions so I'll take you past all of
those
pages I'll take you to the uncorrected
misstatements on page
44 so the reason I draw your attention
to these is obviously we're going to ask
the members to approve the financial
statements or signing it's important
that you understand what errors are
still present there and also I will the
accounting standards require ordering
standards require me to ask you to make
these adjustments I would suggest that
before taking a judgment on that you
would take advice from your section1
officer um but to emphasize these errors
are not so significant that they would
stop before forming a clean opinion I am
content that they're not material but I
need the committee to formally document
their decisions on it in in terms of the
errors that we found there you've got
one which is a section 106 Grant which
you're deferring but the conditions
around it mean you can never give it
back so because you never give it back
under the financial reporting standards
you've got control over it therefore it
should be Revenue uh you had some
incorrect classification of pp's
infrastructure assets um which I talked
about already the capitalization rated
up by DVS on Springfield industrial
estate that outside our expected range
so we've got a bit of a misstatement on
the P value there and then there's N Pay
BS not l a specifical ndr creditor which
we're suggesting should just be
removed
um
so that's they are my errors that are
remaining after the corrections that
have been made and there have been a lot
of Corrections um so as I said um
um I do need to for document their
decision in respect of the uncorrected
misstatements and also in respect to the
disclosure of statement you'll find over
the page which is just an analysis Point
within your cash flow
statement I assume shair you want you
take that at the end of the report
rather than now yes please okay uh I'm
going to take you straight past page 46
and 47 and 48 and 49 and 50 and 51 which
is given for your information that just
explains what we are doing to raise the
quality of our audits in response to
feedback from our
regulator I will take you past page 52
which is again just context to explain
to you what our responsibilities are and
are not in respect to fraud on page 53
we talk about reconfirming our
independence this is kind of important I
do need to Rec confirmed you that I am
independent of the council and therefore
I am still qualified to give you an
independent Auditor's opinion on fees um
we have previously communicated to this
committee the variation to the scale fee
um and when we discovered the extensive
problems in the financial statements I
did flag up to the committee that this
would likely lead to additional audit
fees um I have provided a analysis of
the audit fees to your finance officer
um I don't know how many me Al I can't
see the members and I wasn't here as
originally present I don't know how many
members are still in situation from when
we originally presented but originally
on the 21th 4th of August 2020 we told
the total proposed to be would be £
9,580 That Was Then revised down because
of some changes scope to
8858 the work the the additional work
that we've done and the hours that's
taken now means I have a total proposed
audit fee of
99,500 in
total
um for committee members information the
way this works is we provide a proposal
to the authority and then attempt to
seek agreement if whether we can or
cannot agree it's for the psaa who own
the contract to adjudicate on what a
fair fee is we will make our submissions
to them prob in early January uh setting
out our basis for the fee variation and
they will then seek your opinion as to
what you feel the AIT Fe should
be
um I guess I should also highlight that
we haven't provided any non audit
services to the authority um and that's
it there's a glossery of terms in the
back which uh we were asked to put in
because some of the stuff in here is a
bit auditory
thank you very much that's very helpful
has anybody else wish to um to speak on
this no me um Mr Adu do you anything
to no Toby is here in case you ask me a
really difficult question I don't okay
okay lovely right thank you so nothing
from any other
officers lovely okay so um the
recommendation which is found on page 15
of the report is that members consider
the report of the external auditor at
appendix one I so move do I have a
seconder thank you C
Suson members comments
please yes please councilor spencley
thank you chair um thank you for a very
uh details and helpful report um I've
got a question really for for M Lucas
obviously this predate
your arrival by quite a few years um and
so I'm not going to dwell on the um
asset register and the failure to
depreciate assets so some very robust
management comments which I think are
really helpful uh but there's just one
uh comment on page 27 and 34
which um touches perhaps on a cultural
issue which is uh to quote the council
does not have a clearly documented
process for the determination of the
useful economic life of its assets with
the process relying on the experience of
the asset and maintenance personnel with
minimal documentation being captured as
to how the assets uel have been
determined and that kind of chimes with
things we picked up from peer review and
perhaps other meetings that may be is it
fair to say that we're perhaps moving
towards a more formal process of
documenting things and setting up uh
properly uh controlled processes where
things might have been a little bit
informal and uh uh undocumented in the
past this
Focus thank you um so I mean we have had
um sort of policies in place in terms of
the useful economic life of different
kinds of assets but as you say they
might not have been kind of quite as
clearly documented as we would have
liked um I think there's um
an agreement that there needs to be um a
kind of yeah more clearly documented
process between the asset team and the
finance team and our valuers in terms of
what what what those policies are and
and what those useful economic lives are
um I think the more General Point around
um the ongoing work around documenting
our assets clearly having a good asset
register and making sure the information
around our assets is is more clearly
retained um you're correct there there
is a a piece of work that is already
underway in terms of making sure that
that is robust and that should Aid Us in
terms of our future um accounts and
audit
work thank you thank you yes Council
stand just a couple of points really
just to clarify is deits doing the
following Year's audit I can't
remember um yeah so the next um well the
last two years um delites will be
auditing those accounts as well 21 22
and 22 23 um and then we have a new
auditor KPMG in place from 23
24 thank you chair
so the next question maybe is is a bit
relevant now and I was going to actually
ask the inter the external auditor if
there are any risks um because I I can't
remember it's such a long time ago it's
really unfair asking us to remember you
know a few years ago when we was all up
up up onto all this um is there any
risks because I know was to do with
assets which is why the report was
delayed and the covid grants because we
was originally led to believe the covid
grants it was just a an error on where
they were actually put on the accounts
but then I think you found it wasn't so
uh thank you for actually putting us
right on there even though it seems to
have cost us a heck of a a lot of money
I understand we had to do it but is are
there any more changes coming from
central government that may change the
way the Auditors are operating again
because I could be wrong but is it my
understanding that it was the government
who made you look at our assets
differently or was it a standard uh uh
um an auditor standard that we had
failed to
identify thank you that's one for Mr hon
it is yes and forgive me if I have not
quite followed the question but the
issues I think you're referring to is we
had CID grants which you weren't helped
by government because they wanted you to
make your own mind up as to whether or
not you were agent or principal rather
than just saying these grants are agent
these grants are principal which I never
really understood why they didn't
mandate it because that's how you get
consistency but they left it your
judgment in terms of the asset piece I
wonder if the memb is referring to the
infrastructure assets where there was
government intervention on a change of
accounting policy now that was
instigated because Auditors were finding
it other authorities not like yourself
where there were things like highways
assets and they couldn't work out what
asset they still had and how much it was
worth and the additions over time hadn't
been recorded properly and it was
getting to the point where the a just
couldn't form an opinion and so
government stepped in in order to
unblock that Log Jam with the statutory
instrument that they released on
Christmas Day I think I think it's da
the 25th of December um to give Auditors
a way out of that particular meire um in
terms of central government information
that's coming down the track that might
affect the way the audit is operated the
only thing that I'm hearing at the
moment but it is not yet formalized and
not yet confirmed there is talk about
instigating a back stop date of the 31st
of March
2024 by which all audits before that
must be completed all
must have a disclaimer opinion
issued um alongside that they're saying
the Auditors must complete the vfm work
for 22 and
23 even if they can't complete the
financial statements audit now that's
not been confirmed it's not been
released it's it is at the minute merely
a rumor going around the sector um so
watch this space on that in terms of
other things that might change the way
we have to
operate thank you can I one more yes
please did that answer the question yeah
thank you very much it was it was lovely
cheers um thank you um so I'm being an
optimist tonight so obviously you've
done a lot of the donkey work and you're
going to be our our external auditor for
next year so based on that what in your
expert of opinion on when will we be
getting our next year's accounts ready
to come to this
committee
you've done all the hard work now
haven't you so it should be pretty
straightforward 2122 yeah 2122 2122
thank you so we have already commenced
our audit of the
2122 um financial statements uh we are
trying to get as much of that done pre-
Christmas as we can if we don't get the
work finalized pre- Christmas there then
will be get Hiatus until we can pick it
back up again in March because January
February is an incredbly busy time for
corporate Auditors um
but running alongside that is as I
say the threat of a back stop date that
might mean at some point in March we
have the down tools um what I think we
probably do absolutely have to do is to
focus on trying to get the value for
money work done before
then thank you do that answer your
question canc fabulous any other
members no well um thank you for your
very very comprehensive
report Mr hit and members can we agree
by sense the
recommendation marvelous thank you very
much chair sorry could the committee
please just document their conclusion
respect of the unadjusted errors and
their decision whether to adjust or not
please yes
members what you want is just to not to
chair we want we need a decision Mr H so
so if I may if you could elaborate a
little bit Yeah the question the
committee is whether or not you tend to
adjust for the remaining errors that I
found remain
uncorrected I suggest you take advice
from your finance officer before making
a decision but I am required to ask you
to adjust for them and if you decide not
to to document why you're not going to
but I would strongly suggest you take
advice from your finance officer I am
taking advice from our finance officer
as we speak and that advice is that we
do not adjust is it not yeah if I may um
yes please yeah so I think as um hson
has said um um it's in the gift of the
committee to decide whether they want us
to adjust for these um unadjusted
misstatements um in in my view because
they are not material and because the
work of the audit has been concluded and
the Auditors are happy that the um
accounts not materially mated um the
reasons for those um Mis um unadjusted
misstatements were set out report my my
recommendation would be that we don't
adjust for those because otherwise we
are going to then delay the process in
terms of signing off the accounts
further that that makes sense to me
members are we happy I so propos I'll
second that then councelor Thompson
members can we agree then not to adjust
by
Ascent agreed thank you thank you Mr
hson thank you very much
super so that brings us on to item eight
final statement of accounts
2021 which is on pages 57 to
182 so I'm going to hand over to you
Miss Lucas and then to bring in anyone
else as you wish is that yeah thank
thank you um so this is essentially a
companion report to the the previous
report you've considered um in that it
it's um got the actual um final
statement of accounts um appended to um
the report and I'm asking you to um
consider those accounts in light of the
opinion you've just heard from um
Delights in terms of their their view on
on the um nature of those
accounts um so yeah I'm presenting the
statement of accounts um to you um and
I'm asking that given um that we've just
got to finalize you know just the last
couple of um small bits that
delegated authority is given to myself
um in conjunction with the chairperson
and vice chairperson of the committee
just to do the final sign off of the
approval of the statement of accounts
after this um meeting and including the
annual governance statement which um
members have already considered at
previous committee um and the letter of
representation that needs to be signed
um by myself and the Auditors as well um
so I mean in the terms of the section
three the summary of key issues I've
just set out that um obviously the
content of the statement of accounts um
is determined by a statutory
requirements and we required to comply
with the um relevant Professional
Standards including the code of
practice um there is a deadline in terms
of when we have to um publish the
approved um statement of accounts or as
has been in this case due to the delays
an explanation of why it wasn't possible
to achieve um the publication of those
final accounts by the deadline of 30th
of September 2021 which we did comply
with um as I said at 3.4 the statement
of accounts includes the annual
governance statement which has
previously been um reviewed and approved
by this committee but has just been
slightly updated in terms of and
bringing it up to the latest position in
terms of those governance issues but is
that is also reflected in the final um
statement of accounts which is
appended um and as we said previously um
that Delights have substantially
completed their work and no significant
findings have been found um other than
the ones that Mr hson has um pointed out
um and therefore yeah I'm asking for
that that delegated authority to um just
sign off the final accounts um unless
members have any further questions on
those accounts thank you thank you so
the recommendation is that delegated
authority is given to the interim Chief
finance officer in consultation with the
chairperson and vice chairperson of the
performance governance and audit
committee for the final approval of the
statement of accounts for 2020 21
including the annual governance
statement and letter of representation
corporate plan may not be achieved I so
move do I have a second or counc
Thompson thank you members um any
comments are we happy to um to agree
that by by a sense
agreed agreed marvelous thank you that's
that's great thank you very
much okay so henceforth we whiz on to
item nine which is the let the others go
anybody um may leave now if you have um
if you have finished thank you very very
much for your attendance tonight so feel
free to go and enjoy the rest of your
evening thank you very much K and uh
hopefully we'll see you again short
thank you good night both thank
you right internal audit report Pages
183 to 184 and I have a COR you cop here
of officers to um help with this item
and uh and discuss it some in the
chamber
some remotely and of course our
colleagues from
B so I think now I hand over to um Mr
Aon winter please
thank you chair um good evening everyone
our first report is our progress report
which is Page 185 of your pack um so
this is a a summary report we
periodically bring to this meeting um
and it's covering the finalization of
the 2223 internal audit plan and also
our progress of the 2324 internal audit
program I'm pleased to say that um as
part of this report and later in our
pack we've finalized the final review
from 2223 the cyber security review
um with a substantial opinion on design
and a moderate opinion on operational
effectiveness what I would say is that
those draft um those opinions were
already reflected in our um head of
internal audit opinion for last year um
so that means that the results of those
that report and that finalization of
that report has not altered that opinion
um moving on to
2324 um I'm really pleased with the
progress we're making the engagement
we're getting from management obviously
a good barometer of our progress is the
number of reports you receive ceing at
each committee uh we have another four
on top of the um previous report that we
reported at the last meeting we were
present at so final reports are part of
our later papers covering equality
diversity and inclusion uh sickness and
absence management management of section
106 and Licensing um with regards to the
remainder of our plan for 2324 you will
see from our paper we have a number that
are already in field work and a lot of
those are closing in on draft report
stage uh prior to Christmas so I'm
confid the profile of reporting will
continue to the next meeting um that we
are present at in March um and the
remaining reviews that we've got planned
for quarter 4 are being plan scoped and
uh will be completed in time as well so
what that brings to conclusion on the
2324 plan is we're confident that we'll
be in a position to issue our annual
head of internal audit opinion um on
time in the summer like we always do so
they were the key highlights of that
report I'll stop there and take any
questions if there is any thank you very
much members any questions at this Point
Mr
winter no you got away with the no got
away with that one Mr
winter no that's that's really good I
sure I should mention that we have also
received um via email and update from a
response from CH for City
counciling the licensing item which is
9g okay so we um who we got to next is
it cyber security or is it no it's no
we've got followup of recommendations
yeah chair that's uh my one to present
today fabulous over to you thank you
very much um so the Fallout report is on
page 19 195 of the pack uh as you see we
had 13 recommendations due to be
followed up this quarter and we've
confirmed implementation of 12 which is
a a positive position U I'm pleased to
say all recommendations are now complete
for 1920 there is only one overdue
recommendation for 20 21 which is for
Knowledge Management however we've
confirmed with officers they're still on
track to meet the revised implementation
date of 31st of March
20124 there are still two overdue
recommendations for 2122 for management
of property again we've confirmed with
officers uh for one of these they remain
on target to meet the revised
implementation date of January
2024 the other one was due to be
implemented this quarter but work is
still ongoing so we've agreed a new
implementation date for that one of 31st
of December 2023 so that's the only one
out of the 13 which was not implemented
for this quarter um all other
outstanding recommendations are not yet
due and um yeah I'm ready take any
questions if anyone has any brilliant
thank you any questions for Mr billam
members apparently not which is great
marvelous well thank you very much both
um so now we come on to cyber sec
security Pages 2 And1 226 and I believe
we have Grant remotely to miss H to talk
about
this or do we no we have Miss
cardi you're covering a lot of bases
Miss cardi this
evening I think introduce it and then
I'm sorry I do I do apologize please
please introduce it I shall sit back and
uh
leave it to you thank you it's a good
barom it's good if Management on take
ownership of our reports so it means
we're doing something right which is
great um so it's only fair that
obviously it is our report we own that
so therefore I will introduce it so um I
already touched on it on my progress
report that it the sub Security review
from 2223 received a substantial design
opinion and a moderate operational
opinion and in kind of layman terms that
means that the council have got
effective policies procedures and
controls defined um obviously
operationally it's about how they're
applied and followed and that's where we
found some of the issues that need to be
improved but actually management have
already started to take action on a
number of these points um in the report
um Lots in terms of comparison to other
councils this is obviously a Hot Topic
area we read in the media constantly
about public sector organizations being
attacked I heard a number recently of in
the thousands that it's constant each
day um so um what we have here is that
it's good that the council has got a
number of preventative controls in
operation the two areas of improvement
are actually the areas of if what
happens if something goes wrong so
therefore the kind of the testing of the
recovery procedures and ensuring that we
can continue um uh the services or
reboot the services as quickly as attack
has occurred if any any issues occur was
one of the issues that we found but
again that was more about ensuring that
it was reflective of the current
processes and what the council were
doing um and the other area that we
flagged as an approv movement is the
human input which is obviously the
ability to ensure that the staff are are
aware of what you do how to identify any
sort of threat which whether that's
fishing or um any ability any um unor
link that you're sent um and obviously
the training compliance in our report
does suggest that there is a lot of work
to do to ensure that everyone in the
council is completing that training um I
know from a BDO perspective we have to
do that on an annual basis to ensure
that we stay up to dat with some of the
tech techniques and uh that some of the
fishing and and criminals are trying to
use at this current moment in time
because there's always a human element
you only need that one person to click
on that link so um but overall I'd say
it's a really positive opinion um we
don't often issue substantial in the
area of um cyber security so I would
definitely take that as a positive I'm
happy to take any questions as as
management are I'm sure as well thank
you any questions for Mr winter yes
Council s are you able thank you are you
able to tell us um if we have been
attacked and how many
times I think that would be a question I
don't want to pass it on to management
um
but that way we can tell if you're being
successful or not well I'm I've only
reviewed the processes that are in place
I'm I'm not in the position to prevent
any attacks from occurring that's
actually your it function your Frontline
service that are doing that on a
day-to-day basis okay so can I ask the
management then please think that is one
for hum Miss C isn't
it um we are
um like most organizations under attack
all the time and there as as you
probably find at home as well on your
personal devices um they are becoming
increasingly sophisticated with um Bots
that can do numerous um hits to try and
get in but um they have not been
successful um because of our three
multiactor authentification because of
all the things that have been identified
in this report and have that the do have
checked um and we've also had other
external um independ independent
verification that our cyber is as robust
as it can be now it can never be 100% um
because um we are all uh prone to attack
and and they are very sophisticated so
they do move at a rapid rate to try and
um get into data and
information but um and I think that's
shown by the attacks that happen on big
organizations despite the amount of
infrastructure and security they have in
place so we have everything that we can
have um and as video the we are brought
our size and our infrastructure we have
robust measures in
place brilliant thank you very much
Council Sam back to you so so can we be
reassured that all our internal and our
staff are actually uh trained to the
level as uh as what was mentioned
because you said about um employees and
staff being trained we we know we put in
some some good uh processes and controls
for members because we've all had to sit
there and do this thing and you have to
have 80% to pass this test so is that
still continuing and are we actually
still monitoring I did see on here about
the number of people who've done it but
do you think that is effective or do we
need to look at um encouraging our
members to make sure that we are filling
in this because we're at risk of sharing
things I've had a few come to me and I
always forward it on to uh Mr hully uh
and uh you know we've had a few saying
you know give us an iTunes card your
parents or something has been so would
you say in your your opinion then that
we as members are up to date and up to
scratch and what we should be to
safeguard the council as well as
employees of the council not just your
systems Miss cardi the US members yeah
have have we all done our Big Fish
Little Fish cardboard box training I
have um we are monitoring um that the
staff are complet and the members are
completed um now we have a key
performance indicator that's reported
every month to ensure and really ensure
that this key scrutiny is on this um
we've got very high level of
completions um there are some members
who haven't completed them uh or all of
them so obviously that's um for members
to take forward but for the staff we
monitor very closely every month it goes
to our
CT um and we will
remind um and even um limit the access
staff have until they've completed their
box fist
training brilliant thank you does that
answer your query does but so I know
myself I haven't filled some in so could
I request that we all get a reminder Al
reminder CU I know that when when they
came it was I didn't have the time to do
it and I generally tried to do it so I
think other members have have struggled
to actually complete these and it it is
a a a really good reminder now you've
presented this report to actually give
us the the kick that we require they're
really quick they're really easy
straightforwards five 10 minutes and
yeah listen to
yes you do have to concentrate there was
one I confess I didn't and I didn't pass
it first time and it doesn't let you you
retake it and count your second score
either which I was most disappointed
with because I expected to yeah get at
least two bites of the Cherry with it
but apparently not so thank you um do we
have any more cyber security questions
for either Mr winter or Miss
cardi no apparently not so thank you
very much thank you m cardi so I back to
you then Mr winter for EDI equality
diversity and inclusion thank you y so
this report is Page 227 onwards of your
pack um so just a flag this is an
advisory review so this is about
assessing the maturity of the council's
kind of edni principles policies plans
and actions um I would flag that the
report does bring out that the council
was in the infant infancy in terms of
their plans and this was in ability our
ability to support them in that Journey
um and some of them are longer term
Ambitions and the way that the report is
designed is to say it's a stepping stone
so you can't just go from kind of step
one to step five and that's how we've
then work with management to develop
some of the considerations um that's why
it doesn't generate an opinion this is
more about um about supporting that um
progress um there are 17 findings which
I would say are 17 considerations that
doesn't mean that they're all necessary
to obviously mitigate any particular
risk but what we're finding from these
very focused cultural reviews is it's
actually a massive encouragement to
staff that organizations are invested in
this space it's a great retention tool
people want to work with organizations
that really take these topics seriously
um as they are low priorities we're not
suggesting that uh we as they are low
advisory recommendations they won't be
part of our follow-up uh program however
we have as you can see in the report
management comments and clear actions
that I know management are taking
forward and using this to support their
Journey so that was all I was going to
say on that but it's quite elongated
report as a result of the number of
detail brilliant thank you very much I'd
like to see the word gender replaced
with the word sex personally but I
believe that's the way that things
happen in uh local government and
elsewhere thank you very much for that
so I think we're also back to you Miss
cardi is there anything you wanted to
say um no I think this we did ask BD to
do um an advice
report to should to help us understand
how to develop equalities and diversity
um we it's I just reassure members that
we do have some statutory duties under
the equality act and we have met all of
those and we do meet all of those each
each year so this is just a framework
that the government provides to V for
public bodies to to help evolve their
Journey um and that's why we've done it
and as you can see there's a lot of
management uh responses to the
recommendations the things that we're
going to do to help um progress that
Journey as a small Authority it's quite
difficult um we don't have a team of
equality officers um we are doing this
as addons to the day job um but we do
feel it is really important and that's
why we've made those responses to those
recommendations
fabulous thank you very much any further
questions on that on ADI yes C sent a
comment really please page 239 we keep
saying this we're a committee system not
a cabinet system so in future can the
reports not use a cabinet system we're a
committee system if you don't mind
please thank you very much and it's
important to us that we are isn't it
councilor stamp it C well certainly is
to me thank you very much for that
so now we go
to management of section 106 funds on
pages 257 to
270 Mr
wi so again just a brief highlight of
this report so it's a moderate opinion
for both design and operational
effectiveness and that's generally
driven by the two medium findings that
are in the report um the scope of the
review obviously section 106 is such a a
broad um remit that we focus the scope
on this is the collection of payments
under those agreements and um and also
ensuring that the funds are
appropriately allocated in line of those
agreements um that was our remit um we
do note in the report that there are
manual processes operating and monitor
monitoring um that is occurring uh we're
not suggesting there are numerous errors
or or but it is open to human error it's
reflective of an organization this size
and therefore investment in a system is
possible but actually at the moment and
as management have responded in this
report it needs the additional around
the kind of the the seal Etc to take on
board that and maybe that will then give
the requirement to invest in such a
system um some of the findings that
we've included in here around the
trigger points were actually more around
that audit trial and clear documentation
we're not suggesting that they were
missed because obviously you'll see
there in our report that payments were
received when required um but it's more
about that proactivity especially if
volume increases as well um and then the
other key finding was more around the
formalization of approvals on section
106 spend um again this goes back to the
greater Clarity Point around
documentation we're not suggesting that
approvals on the finance system weren't
there it's more around those due
diligence checks that are occurred
before the funds are then allocated to
the relevant project um it's about
having that um checklist as has been
recommended and accepted by Management
in there to offer that additional
evidence of that fault process so that
was all I was going to say on that and
happy to take any questions thank you
any questions to Mr to or should we go
to um mof Shand who I know has got some
some things to
say do you want to go ahead um this Al
of Shand or um there were some of the
recommendations we've already done so
we've set out a process already we've
put a column in the housing spreadsheet
because that the two are linked um so
that everybody knows when um an
application's got section 106 I mean I
know cuz I deal with it but so that
everybody knows now um we've set up a
little working group looking at um
tightening up the governance
Arrangements about how we allocate the
spend we've already done that so that'll
be feeding back probably January um into
I think it probably comes into this um
this
committee lovely thank you don't know Mr
Winslow if you've got anything you wish
to
add uh hello um I I don't have anything
chair to add further to what M Auto sh's
already said thank you very much best
ask just in case so any questions for um
Mr winter or for officers members on
106 Council stamp please I said I might
not say anything tonight I do apologize
I'm glad you are so thank you thank you
um I'm actually pleased to actually read
this because we have been concerned
about section 106 is and the possible
missing and the trigger dates um for
quite some time uh I've read the report
and that it is going to be put on the on
the spreadsheet so it's going to be easy
to identify so I congratulate you on
that it is a bit of a shame that it it
the findings and I won't go into it
because members have most probably read
it that we haven't had some supporting
uh documentation at authorization
documentation so whatever was identified
and I welcome this report for being
thorough because we don't want to lose
our section 106 monies cuz we get hardly
anything to improve our infrastructures
for this District as it is so uh I
actually uh welcome you for that and an
I should be looking forward to when you
actually do produce these sheets and
that we can all see them uh in the
future so no questions but well done and
thank you very much that's great thank
you positivity lovely I told you I'm
positive I know Positive Vibes that's
what we like so then we move on to
sickness and absence management please
yep so I'll be taking this one so this
is on page 271 of the pack and uh the
purpose of this audit was to ensure the
council has adequate controls and
triggers in place to Monitor and manage
sickness absence
effectively uh this has received a
substantial Assurance rating both for
the design of the control framework and
the operation of of controls which is a
very positive result and shows there are
strong controls in this area lots of
areas of good practice including a sound
sickness absance management policy clear
training provision testing confirmed
cases are dealt with in accordance with
Council processes ongoing monitoring and
reporting of sickness Trends there's
only one low priority finding about
making sure policies are appropriately
reviewed and that's it really so it's a
very strong area with a very positive
Assurance
rating good stuff thank you m cardi
anything you wanted to
add um no only that um it's that um
we're very robust in our absence
management which we um need to be
because obviously sickness is a cost to
the council um and has an imput on an
impact on colleagues um that have to um
fulfill the the person's role that's off
um but at the same time we really
support people that um need support
during their sickness the one
recommendation we've actually looked at
so we'll be feeding that back to BD
after this meeting um as we look at the
actions going
forward thank you brilliant thank you
again more more good news members any
questions oh thank you oh hello can I
just say thank thank you for this report
as well um no no questions as such but
it's great that we've got the reporting
procedures um where does it come into
play that we're actually doing the
things to make sure we're keeping our
staff and our staff happy I know you're
going to turn around and say it's not
for this it's for the performance or
something um to come to us but it does
concern me we can have every little
thing in the book to say that we're
following processes procedures which is
exactly what you've just said and you
know that is great but I you know I do
know that this Council as in a lot of
councils in the in the country have got
sickness problems so is there is there
anything that we've learned from this
this m Cardy that all these forms that
we fill in and the policies we've got
that we can learn from for our staff to
make it
better thank you I think it's about just
putting all of the things you know
although it is a lot about process there
is a lot of support as well and that's
why we um have an employment assistant
program we have mental health advisors
that are trained within the council um
so looking at this policy and the
procedures it's not just about looking
at how we um look at the staff that are
SI is also about the mechanisms that are
in place to help people manage in work
um during periods of sickness or health
um and also to get them back into work
quickly and support them with things
like phase return and then as I say the
um employee assistant program
all of the well-being um tool kits and
seminars that we have access to so it's
very much um supported of support you
know of providing support to employees
as much as managing them when they do go
off great thank you any further
questions no marvelous I think that
takes us to license
y that's that's me as well so licensing
is the last report um that's on page 283
of the pack and the purpose of this
audit was to ensure there are sufficient
controls over the management of issuing
and maintaining licenses and whether
there are appropriate controls in place
to ensure effective recovery of fee
income so this got an assurance rating
of moderate for both the design and the
operation of the controls um our our
work highlighted five areas for
improvement so there's one high three me
medium and one low priority
recommendations the high priority
recommendation was around making sure
DBS and medical checks for vehicle
licenses are consistently reviewed the
median recommendations regarding
ensuring supporting evidence is always
saved in a central location checking
ratable value values for premises
licenses to ensure correct fees are paid
and ensuring public registers of
licenses are up to dat um and then the
low prty recommendation is just around
regularly reviewing and updating
policies um I think the council's
already taking action to to implement
some of these recommendations and um
which is which is a positive sign I'm
I'm happy to take any questions
brilliant any questions for Mr winter on
that or should we go to um Mrs Wheatley
who's going to give us the officer
response Mrs weatley I think thank you
very much chair good evening members
good evening I'd like to update good
evening I'd like to update this
committee on the licensing report
recommendations in terms of progress to
date and actions we intend taking over
the coming weeks we have Mr Paul Brooks
who is the director for sustainable
communities from Champs City Council in
the chamber and Mrs Shirley Hall from
Mor District Council on teams who are
both happy to take
questions Mr Brooks provided an earlier
response to members on behalf of Champs
city council which includes comments on
the report
recommendations the audit has been
particularly useful in identifying areas
of improvement and where additional
monitoring training and process
improvements are necessary over the next
four months m has a dedicated resource
who will be working towards improving
the current licensing process to enable
us to Accord to the recommendations set
out in the audit report they'll be
working closely with our colleagues at
chood city council to deliver these and
put in place the necessary system
enhancements reporting and
monitoring in relation to the five
report
recommendations for the first one on the
DBS and medical record monitoring this
will be the first recommendation we will
focus on on we'll be working on various
system improvements to ensure that the
necessary checks are completed by
introducing prompts activated by the
systems which will become mandatory we
will include an activity within the
service plan to ensure a measurable
action is reportable going
forward so number two which is
insufficient application evidence
training is proposed for this
recommendation and is key to the proper
indexing of documents chancel city
council are currently preparing a
validation checklist for all license
types which will be incorporated by it
development of the systems this will
require it resource and so those
conversations will be
ongoing the ratable value checks the
recommendations are already underway
customer services are completing a
project by reviewing existing licensed
premises and checking these against our
current ratable values system
improvements are proposed to require
rable value checks for renewals on new
licenses going
forward but for the license register
updates there is currently a system
report that collects data manually once
per month we're exploring a system
prompt to ensure that the report is
drawn at the same time each month other
processes and training requirements will
occur as part of this recommendation to
ensure the system data is accurately
captured by chelsford city
council and finally for the out ofd
policies the draft review of the
gambling policy is being presented to
the licensing committee on the 28th of
November
a consultation period of 28 days will
follow and the results of which will be
included in the final version which will
go back to the licensing Committee in
the New Year we are working to align the
policies with the review period of chanc
city council policies as this will
ensure they remain current and are
reviewed by the licensing team in
accordance with the SLA we also intend
to generate automatic reminders via
share points in advance of the Pol
policies expiring so that's it from me
we're now happy to take any questions
thank you thank you thank you does Mrs
Hall have anything to to
add no oh hello no sry anything to add
no lovely quite clear so nothing to add
thank brilliant thank you Mr Brooks
anything well really I'd just like to
say that um when we received the audit
we were concerned because of the level
of service we provide for mold in in
licensing this this appeared to fall
below what we would expect and we're
especially concerned about the um it
looked like that we're issuing licences
without having all the information um
necessary and actually the work we've
done since it it transpires that we had
all that information we were just
holding it in separate files within the
the mold system so it wasn't as serious
as what CH Council first um appeared and
really I we circulated that note just to
reassure members of molden um that we do
take this seriously we we always provide
a high quality um service to molden
District Council and we we'll continue
that and just I'm here to reassure you
that that's the case fantastic thank you
very much for that Mr Brooks so members
questions for anyone Council
spencely yes thank you uh yes I was
alarmed as a new member of the licensing
committee I read my glossy magazine and
um
uh read about Rogue taxi drivers so uh
yes I I I did get a bit alarmed and it's
reassuring um to see uh that the
controls really were in place and this
is simply a case of miscommunications so
I'd like to thank the Auditors for
highlighting this and um our own team
and Chelmsford for responding so
robustly because uh you know these kind
of safeguarding issues are the kind of
things that could go very badly wrong uh
and it's just good to see that this
certainly wasn't as bad anything like as
bad as we thought and that now we've got
a system that systems that speak to each
other and give us the reassurance we
need brilliant thank you councelor
spencley any other
members no I think it's an indication of
how thorough all um reports have been
that we have so few questions so again
many many thanks to um everybody who has
uh come and provided information so the
recommendations members on page
71 are that we consider comment and
approve the following little one
progress report at 9A little two
followup of recommendations reports at
9B little three cyber security at 9 C
little four equality diversity and
inclusion at
9d little 4 five management of section
106 funds at
9e six sickness sickness and absence
management at 9f and little seven
licensing at 9g I so moved I have a
second thank you can Thomson members any
other comments or questions or are we
happy to agree by
Ascent fantastic and again thank you
very very much to all the officers and
um our guests tonight thank you very
much for for your contributions much
appreciated which brings us on to item
10 any other items of business that the
chairman of the committee decides are
Urgent um I have
none so members thank you very very much
for your contributions this evening and
I now draw the meeting to a close at
8:36
p.m. thank
you